Around ten years ago, I left my home town
in the north-west of Argentina, and I could
not envision that I would be speaking today
to all of you.
Thank you.
Earlier this week, I was asking any speakers
if they had rituals before they went on stage.
This is the largest audience IBA been in front
of.
Laurie Voss suggested I take a selfie to help
with my stage fright.
If that is okay with you, can we take one
at least?
Thank you so much!
So we've got it here.
Can we say "actors"!
One, two, three, actors!
Okay.
It was worth a shot.
So, all right, for those of you who don't
know me, my name is Leandro, and I work as
a research engineer at Source.
We're fully open source non-profit dedicated
to advance humanity in our interactions with
computers.
Today, I'm here to talk about us.
All of us.
And about our history-building software for
human beings.
By the end of this talk I hopefully will have
done two things.
While the web flourishes with incredible ideas,
we have a great many lessons to learn from
our past.
The second one is that was perhaps I will
have compelled some of you to challenge the
way we build web applications, both at a technical
level but also philosophically.
So let us begin.
And in the spirit of fun, let's play a gale.
I will describe a programme and some of the
features it has, and you will try to guess
out loud its name.
Are you up for it?
Yeah?
Cool.
I know we are tired, the last day, but please,
bear with me.
Can you think of a programme that lets you
draw maybe free handed, and then you can resize
your shapes at will?
Does this programme let you set constraints
for those shapes and say that they will be
centred, parallel to something else?
Can you make copies of those shapes?
And if you make a copy and update the regional,
does the copy update as well?
Anybody any guesses?
Photoshop?
Anyone else?
All right, I was hoping would actually say
"Sketch".
These are some of the features in Sketch but
I was referring to subscribers sketch Pad,
a programme developed back in 1963, and yet
this is this old.
This is really over 50 years old.
So I want to show you a little bit of what
Sketch Pad looks like.
We can see that something on screen, right.
It looks like a rivet or maybe some sort of
square with a base.
He has a crossbar, and the centre of the crossbar
now to draw an arc.
Then he's going to point to the different
edges of the drawing and ask the programme
to make them mutually perpendicular.
As the problem solves the constraints, it
forces the arc to change.
Then he shows that no matter how you distort
it, it comes up with a symmetrical solution,
which is pretty cool.
These constraints could have been more complicated,
could have been ratios between lines, and
other drawings.
We will see a last example there.
Turns it on.
There you go.
Perfectly symmetrical rivet.
Another important idea we will see here, and
the first time it is shown, is the idea of
a master and an instance, right?
He was working before on this master drawing,
and now he has an instance of it on screen
that is completely independent from the master.
You can see that he's rotating it, trying
to fit it into the plank.
It's a tedious process.
It takes a little bit of time.
This flickers because it's not actually a
display, it's an oscilloscope.
They did not have displays back then.
Perfect.
There you go.
We can relate now to this pattern using different
names.
Perhaps we think of components and elements
in React or classed as an object in JavaScript.
He creates a few more instances, and then
he goes back to the master, and you can see
that he will just remove some of the crossbar
lines, and, when he goes back, lo and behold,
the copies, the instance was be the elements
have been updated.
Yes.
This is the work of Ivan Sutherland who, in
1963, published his seminal work on Sketch
Pad.
It's pretty intense.
It's on line.
This development during the thesis, all by
himself, and when Alan Okay one of his students,
asked him how did he manage to create this
first object-orientated system, and the first
graphical interface system all within one
year by himself, the guy just replied he didn't
know it was hard.
Which is interesting.
Either way, Ivan really set the bar high for
a people that came after him, right?
He set the direction for the likes of Douglas
Engelberg, the fellow who created the first
computer mouse.
They developed through a span of ten years
a system that is kind of incredible.
I can't quite grasp that it has existed.
This is the online system for historical reasons
that I'm not going to get into, and it was
first made publicly in 1968.
In dates a long time ago as well.
This has been dubbed "the mother of all demos".
Let's look at why.
And this is audio, so hopefully, you will
be able to see it.
>> [Video]: I would like to see you while
I'm working on it.
Oops.
The kind of display.
I would like to see you while I'm working
on it.
So before I can do that, I have to set up
my display in a certain way.
>> We can hear Douglas doing the live stream
of the computer.
>> [Video]: It leaves a corner up there.
[Voices speak all at once].
>> You can see my work, I can point on the
at it, and we can talk.
Let's do some collaborating.
>> That is video conferencing 1968.
>> There is nobody here but a large audience,
Bill.
Let's talk about information retrieval, and
a lot of things I've been showing them jumping
around and finding your way.
>> Can we lower the volume on the video, please?
>> "An instrument, complex data structures,
it shows them how we can get around and find
things.
I showed them the content analysers ..."
>> They're discussing some matters of the
presentation they were doing there, and then
they proceeded to link work spaces to the
point that they are essentially doing live-coding.
If you look carefully, in a second from now,
two mouses on the same computer.
They're modifying the same environment.
This is live coding.
This presentation is epical.
If you haven't watched it, after this talk,
wherever you're home, look at it on YouTube.
You see two mouses there.
With this contextual background, we can move
on to the last piece of history that we need
for this presentation, and that is Xerox Park,
the Palo Alto research centre.
They create the Smalltalk.
Smalltalk is a language that was designed
to be a - Smalltalk was designed to be a vehicle
for human symbiosis, not like in Star Trek.
It's a language that is designed to fade into
the background fast and let you express yourself,
sort of like a musical instrument would.
It offers the programmers two core capabilities:
the first one is classes and objects, which
are used to represent things, right, and processes,
and the second one is message-passing.
That provides the communication layer, a way
for the objects to talk to each other.
Something worth noting is that Alan Okay has
repeatedly said that when he invented object-orientated
programming, the important part was not the
objects themselves but the messages.
It was the communication that he really cared
about.
Let's look at an example of this system.
We can see here an animation of a bowl in
what appears to be a static website.
In reality, the animation is being programmed
as objects.
We can stop it, step through it.
It's going to go through until it finds the
right frame.
He opens up a browser, and this browser lets
you see the messages that this object in particular
can receive, right?
That you can send to it.
After finding the right message, he is kind
of going to the painter tool and doing the
same thing, and finding that, okay, we have
the current frame message on the top, and
we need to find a message to link the current
frame into the painting tool.
So it's going to look for the picture arrow.
It's going to then sort of sketch an arrow,
and the system will recognise that you have
to messages selected, so you can type in there
what you want to say.
He's saying, hey, painter, here's a message
picture, give me the picture that you're currently
using and link it to the bouncing, which is
the name of the object which represents the
animation, current frame.
So the current frame of the animation above.
After he sends the message, we get the frame
below.
This is done completely live.
This is not something that has been prepared
beforehand.
It's the live system that the user is going
to use.
Right?
All of these applications are customisable
by the users to feed their needs.
They turn the whole computer into some bicycle
for the mind.
And all of these examples have been built
on each other to formalise the idea that our
world is concurrent.
Everything around us is happening in parallel
from us.
We communicate with everything around us by
sending these metal, just like right now,
I'm not letting you access the memory in my
head, I'm sending mention to you so we communicate.
Yes.
The underlying philosophical grounds that
all of these people shared, the vision they
had, was to advance the human intellect.
We're not talking about for-profit companies
trying to lure you into buying a product but
altruistic men and women dedicating the lives
for all of us.
We've seen the sketch about the NLS - Smalltalk.
What are the learning we can take from them
and apply today?
I want to talk about two ideas.
The first one is the competition model behind
this application, how is it that they're run,
and the second one is the philosophy behind
it?
Let's begin with a first one.
When we model an application in Smalltalk,
we model it in terms of objects that interact
with each other in terms of message-passing
and each of those objects performs hopefully
one small task.
That's a number of messages that it understands
that it sends to all their objects.
It may have some internal state that can change
over time.
Normally, one of these Smalltalk applications,
right, can have millions, or hundreds of millions
of objects, and you may even think of those
tiny objects as tiny computers on their own.
It's kind of like an internet inside your
application.
If you look at this diagram, you can see we
have some ... that is sending essentially
an in put object, a message called "clear",
and it clears itself, and a container object
is sending a draw message telling where it
has to be drawn, the same with a slide er
linked to the graph, and the synchronise from
send to the graph that will in turn update
the slider.
The underlying principles behind how Smalltalk
works have been formalised with some differences
as the Actor model.
In the Actor model, we have separate actors,
essentially independent entities, that they're
executed completely independently, completely
in isolation.
They solve problems by collaboration, and
then collaborate with each other by message-passing.
They collaborate by talking to each other
just like humans do.
Modelling the system with this approach history
is interesting properties.
The first one is failure ... by default.
The second one is an asynchronous nature,
and the second one is that it is parallelisable.
A show of hands: have you ever seen an application,
a website that bass completely unusable because
of some exception that blew up the complete
application stack?
Yes or no?
Pretty everyone is yeah, that's the way it
goes.
I think we all have, right?
Before application s start normally compose
of those independent ly collaborating systems,
why do we treat them as a single monolith
that has to be carefully programmed?
I don't quite understand that.
We know that applications are scaling massively
in complexity, and for the user experiences
that people that used them is perhaps the
definition of a ... for some of us.
In the Actor model, an actor failing does
not take down the entire system.
If you build it carefully, all the actors
can take a look at your actors, and restart
them whenever they fail.
You have a system that heals.
Of course, we could decide the certain failures
are worth a complete application crash, irrecoverable
crash.
Now it's a constant decision that we make.
It's not something that just happens.
The second thing I want to talk about is asynchronous
nature.
This is fairly straightforward.
The applications that we build are asynchronous
by default.
The user interacts with it and we don't know
when that is going to happen.
Why do we need to build up stacks of reactive
libraries, we could be using a competition
model that is fit for it?
Lastly, parallelisable.
We struggle to parallelise this because we
have a accessible stack running, and any co-ordination
in the thread has been thought about beforehand
and done manually.
In terms of actors, we could potentially run
every Actor parallelly.
That might be useless because some might depend
on messages from each other but you can do
that.
This is because each one of the actors is
essentially its own tiny computer.
Just think of the performance gains some applications
would have by using more cores because they
are available.
Without having to be rewritten.
There is this three properties, right.
They are incredible in practice like in Erlang
or Pony been when they are used for building
massively concurrent systems, like WhatsApp,
for example, were built on it.
I will grant you that we don't want two million
users per browser but knowing your application
can crash and recover on the fly by itself,
it's incredibly powerful when it comes to
raising the bar on quality of any experience
that we design or develop.
The second point I wanted to make beyond the
competition model is the one of philosophy.
This is a briefer one.
It's the last point I like to make today.
And it is that most applications, if not all
of them, are built on two key ideas: the idea
of liveness of an application, and the idea
of directness of an application.
When we talk about liveness, we are talking
about the ability to always respond to a user's
actions.
This means that whatever you do in the system,
and whatever the system is doing, they will
never be a complete stop or gap in the feedback
loop.
This is a little bit how the real world works.
We are constantly sending messages, sometimes
we get responses back, sometimes, we get,
you know, double-tick red.
But naturally, as the workload of the system
increases, you will expect some performance
degradation.
You would expect the system to gracefully
degrade without actually stopping to work
entirely.
Now, do you remember the last time you were
a were on a website that didn't do something
or anything, really, for some time.
There was perhaps something taking over the
main loop, and your application just sort
of stopped working entirely.
Really, we can do much better than that.
And I think considering liveness and the actor
model how they work together in isolation
is foundational to recoverable errors.
The second thing in the philosophy track is
directness, or directness.
Directness means that everything you see can
be modified, whatever the user sees on screen
that he can click on, whatever graphical representation
of the system we have is the point that the
user can begin to explore the entire system.
That might be scary for some because you can
right-click on something and get the actual
source and not bundled or minified version
of it and modified.
If they can inspect the button, change the
attributes to restructure the behaviour, even
reconstruct a user employee to suit their
needs better, persist those changes and essentially
modify everything they already see, we have
an application that show cases directness.
Really this is a deeper philosophical question
to ask to all of you here, is are we going
to be building applications that model a flow
that everybody sort of understands and doesn't
actually empower anybody to do better than
they actually are doing?
Are we going to be giving them bicycles for
their processes, or are we going to carry
them around?
So how do we get there?
I would inventory ure the that most of you
who haven't heard of me before so it's hard
to agree with me right now that we need to
rethink the complete foundations on which
we build applications.
After all, with all those fancy frameworks
out there, backed by corporations, how could
they be wrong, right?
I invite you to take a first step in this
world by trying out Smalltalk.
Just to get a feeling of what we are missing
in web development nowadays.
What is it like to build user interfaces,
applications, user experiences in other platforms?
... and it should be more than enough to show
why some of these attributes are paramount
to increasing the quality of the software
we build.
You will find that the same properties alongside
highly, highly reflective language allow for
a development experience quite unlike we've
seen in other mainstream languages.
Seriously, most importantly, what is it we
can do right now to start building web apps
like it's 1972?
My best answer to all of you is to start by
learning about them.
Look online for videos, people that put screen
casts on how to build these applications with
these technologies.
There are languages out there from like Smalltalk,
with Self Squeak, just random names.
I feel like I'm reading a lot of npm packages
right now!
Really try to get inspired.
Take a look at how they're thinking, what
is it they want to give the users?
Are they trying to solve the problem?
Are they trying to give them a tool.
Start by asking why are we treating people
as cattle to put through a conversion funnel
instead of empowering them to solve their
problems by giving them flexible systems with
powerful tools to be as efficient, and effective,
at their jobs as they can be.
I'm sure we are aware there are learning curves
for these things.
But if this community is capable of anything,
it's growing and learning, so there's no good
reason to stop doing what we are doing.
Do not stop doing what we are doing and reconsider
it.
We can begin today with a fundamental philosophical
shift.
At source, we are working as hard as we can
to implement a universal virtual machine,
a Stage VM, that we can use to bring this
computational model on some of the goodies
that BBC seen in these languages to the WebAssembly.
It's not just to target the browser but to
do it through WebAssembly.
It will be something we have worth demoing,
but if you're interested, follow us on Twitter.
And with that, I want to say if you're interested
in non-profits for software, I work at one.
If you're interested in the actor model or
want to learn more about Smalltalk or Erlang
distributed systems, come and say hi to me
after the talk.
Thanks for the opportunity, and thanks to
JSConf.